a una escena que ha causado conmoción en
el salvador y en méxico pero también la
muerte de la salvadoreña victoria
salazar a manos de cuatro policías en la
ciudad de tulum pesó en la inauguración
del foro generación igualdad la
conferencia internacional que se celebra
en la ciudad de mexico busca determinar
acciones concretas para avanzar hacia
los objetivos en materia de igualdad
fijados por la onu para el 2030 sin
embargo durante la ceremonia de apertura
la atención recayó en la condena del
homicidio de victoria salazar la mujer
salvadoreña muerta a manos de la policía
mexicana el pasado sábado a causa de una
fractura en la columna durante su
violenta detención desde el día mismo
del asesinato el mandatario salvadoreño
nadie buque le pidió justicia estoy
seguro que el gobierno mexicano aplicará
todo el peso de la ley a los
responsables mi pésame para la familia
de victoria sobre todo a sus dos hijas
el presidente mexicano aseguró que no
habrá impunidad para los policías
implicados en la muerte de salazar que
serán procesados por feminicidios
castigado a los responsables de este
crimen
brutal
el vergonzoso
y doloroso es decir
por otro lado el presidente francés y el
secretario general de naciones unidas
pronunciaron discursos más amplios de
denuncia a la brecha y a la violencia de
género acentuada por la pandemia
kobe 19 también nos ha recordado la
persistencia de la violencia que sufren
las mujeres esta pandemia en la sombra
que se alimenta de las situaciones de
confinamiento en el exterior del palacio
nacional la protesta de un grupo de
mujeres recordaba que la cercanía de la
muerte de salazar con la celebración del
foro no es una coincidencia temporal en
méjico diez mujeres son asesinadas cada
día